[Music]
and it's not that serious news shut up
some advice sponsor me [ __ ] it's
not that serious
a lifestyle blogger received death
threats after posting a photo of
pancakes that were actually tortillas
Wow bro it's not that there yet
yeah people get that piss online these
days I love it
you're not culturally or do you think
they're like chillin but then they just
type pissed what if that ball like is
all on ethanol you mean yeah like a girl
you know how a girl like you're telling
me like how like inside it's like here
but that outside like yeah babe are you
okay no I'm just I'm just I just didn't
like how the water came up that that's
really interval I totally relate is this
one of those like my culture is not your
your pancakes thing or probably I people
gotta front so hard I know a lot of
Mexican restaurants that serve pancakes
please tell me how food no it wasn't
about that it was more about how fake
her posted so people were just really
bothered who likes you use food props
and she's like hmm
well turkey is around pancakes around
having breakfast with the [ __ ] I'll
read her caption and then I'll show you
the photo she wrote the best of days
start with a smile and positive thoughts
and pancakes and strawberries and
bottomless tea my morning routine is now
live on YouTube and while I don't show
you my real bedhead trust me it's not
pretty
I do give you a little insight into how
I start my day in a positive way head
over to my stories for a swipe off link
and let me know what you think it
features my morning habit of rinsing
with Listerine advanced white to help
whiten my teeth
Atlas dream Ireland hashtag bring out
the bull hashtag add yeah
so this is our post get paid girl so far
so good
pretty average those are not tortillas
damn they make their every
Wow yeah it's like a full-on like it's a
set yeah there's like our declaration
for you see that lift the read in the
back like [ __ ] has Listerine next to
their beds like on their bed Stan that's
what people are saying like he's just
[ __ ] clean
I mean she's look bloggers that's a plus
she's a fake-ass [ __ ] tip say it will
ya know I think like honestly I mean my
perspective on this whole thing it's
like why would you expect a blogger that
has all her photos super made-up and
done like why would you expect this she
really woke up this way if I was rich I
would hire interior designers set
designers to [ __ ] do that [ __ ] while
I'm sleeping so I could wake up like
that and they ain't get surprised so I
wake up in this [ __ ] balloons and
[ __ ] and I'm like oh yeah and I get the
Listerine gargle spit it on the floor
cuz I'm gonna get new carpeting and then
be like clean it up you'll clean it up
clean it that's the [ __ ] I'm rich in
urine up yep
wait so why don't why are people pissed
cuz obvious this is a confessional
Instagrammer right yeah
her PJ's are color-coordinated to the
balloons her hair's done I love this
[ __ ] where she's like believe it or not
I wake up with Bed Head it's like her
hair's done god damn it's like look it's
like you know she's like I know you all
think I'm perfect it's like [ __ ] that's
the [ __ ] that pisses me off I'm was like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] all yourself I know I
know you're I know you I get you I get
who you are
I already yeah it's not dopey don't be
alarmed but she probably also gets that
from her audience that are commenting
you're perfect oh my god you're so
perfect how did you do that so she's
probably [ __ ] you guys are dumb but she
believe it or not I have been hit really
well no but she it's like she always
surprised that they projected their own
image and brand that way yeah SS filet
yeah it's like wow do you guys can
believe it I'm a real person it's like
did we know you're a good person [ __ ]
you no no like Bart is he has a point
I'm not smart
I'm very dumb a lot of people don't know
some people are that [ __ ] dumb and
they think that they really wake up that
pretty not only
right now we're living in a generation
where all these little kids like 10 year
olds have Instagram accounts and that's
all bindi are dumb so they are just
that's all they see and then they get
frustrated because they don't wake up
with balloons next to them and pancakes
mystery you know Listerine all the
bedstead talking [ __ ] to this girl like
how dare you set up all these
unrealistic expectations for all these
people you should die you should
suffocate on the balloon just doing her
job
it's a professional and I'm followed
that's like that's what living in
America is all about you see something
you don't like
unfollow go on your [ __ ] amazing their
age requirement for Instagram she's not
America she's not in America
where is she that's the beauty of these
from the UK that's the beauty of the
Internet
well it's calm English common law okay
thank you
is there age requirement for Instagram
but no one listens to that he's a what
13 is the age was [ __ ] dogs I have
instagrams yeah Jake a sec cuz it's
super hard to say that you're you know
scroll down and say like I was born in
1975 I don't know man if the kids that
[ __ ] dumb cuz I when I was like 10
and [ __ ] like I knew all the fake [ __ ]
like I was are you trying to sell me
something I smell that [ __ ] bozo you
got street smart
well man they need a wise up cuz they're
gonna get booked they're pointing out
that these aren't pancakes tortilla let
me see you can it see they are crepes
they're not they're great they look like
crepes meat yeah they're not tortillas
they are really is that a picture of
your people are like your faces on the
blanket and they'll take her seriously
there's so many clues like and then like
her cup is empty what nobody has
Listerine on their nightstand nobody
wakes up with balloon nobody wakes up
with their own face and their [ __ ]
bet spray either there's so much
evidence of a professional photo shoot
and they think it's dirty - holy [ __ ]
yeah that's like watching a movie and
going that's not real this [ __ ] is all
fake
in this movie you're all dumb that's not
real why don't you all cry when this
person died they didn't really die I'm
sorry that's exactly what it is it's
like an adventure movie or like that
type of world at least the other ones I
don't know that is pretty dumb or even
like I guess something more related like
you're watching a commercial nobody
believed that commercial can really in a
commercial have dogs sometimes talk or
whatever mm-hmm dogs don't really talk
that's basically what they're saying
yeah TIFF let's not go crazy here dogs
my dog can communicate with me let me
talk your dog [ __ ] that Nikki does to me
man
she's like okay franklin's he is
communicating with they do communicate
right exactly no they really do but
exactly I love this [ __ ] do you have any
like samples of comments or anything
like that then it blew up it's just like
was she saying herself she says like a
lot of her comments are to affect that
she's a danger to young women and she
sure suffer and she should be stopped if
she should suffocate balloons she should
kill herself because of how pathetic she
is and that those are like the more
dream
here's the thing though I don't think
people actually care about those things
I see a huge difference between how
women get attacked online versus how
guys get attacked and I think women who
are just jealous will find whatever the
[ __ ] they can like whatever dirt to hurt
the girl and say [ __ ] like yeah you're
gonna [ __ ] Massacre babies or some
random [ __ ] guys do it to those I see it
dramatically on women though well guys I
mean your comments so those [ __ ] up
comments also come from them yeah yeah
that's what I mean like but girls get a
bad NORs thing guys get it worse yes but
you know it's crazy though most of the
hate comments that I get they're like
80% from guys like I well all of our
audiences is mainly guys like yeah yeah
but we do share similar audience like
compared to beauty gurus oh yeah that's
a call girls for sure like our majority
women they can't wait to hate no matter
who it is depending on
is really irrelevant because everyone
just hates success or they when they
can't have what you have or they hate
that they can't have you and a lot of
games yeah yeah and that's the boys that
are trying to talk [ __ ] it's always the
guy they can't have sex with you well to
like their if you go to like Fitness
ones for example all the guys are just
talking [ __ ] to guys yeah I think it's
just it matters what industry you're in
you sexy [ __ ] how do guys talk [ __ ] in
the and the fitness ones my biceps as
big as in you're like oh you're doing
that wrong or you don't know what you're
doing or you're obviously fit because
you're on juice or like they just talk
so much it's like the same petty mindset
but now adapted to fitness terms that
don't mean anybody they're trying to
like make NBA type calls and the guys
just benching and like some commercial
gym it's like look at them they're fake
plates it's like this tall Olympics I
cares you're just [ __ ] working out a
24 hour you have the integrity of
working out of 24 hours what they're
trying to understand look I'm lucky
because I don't have as much I'd like
look on other peoples pages and I'm like
[ __ ] man y'all got some [ __ ] up people
coming over to you and I'm like damn
dude it's rough yeah this work not me
you're so light you know it's tough to
be so light right I don't think I
attract you're also clowning yourself a
lot you don't take yourself super
seriously and you're really good at
interacting with your fans where you can
filter out the [ __ ] you know I mean
a lot of these other people that don't
really you're just a fun hang and I'm
not as popular as all these other people
with millions are the main reason that's
a big part if your company's in millions
and millions of followers you just can't
hold back how many people will talk [ __ ]
those her name is scarlet London by the
way so scarlet was just saying how so
she posted something else up that was
more like addressing this whole thing
and she was saying that she's a strong
24 year old woman who has experienced
bullying in the past and that she will
be okay after this she lived on the
earth not exactly sure she will be okay
after this hideous a strong 24 year old
woman but another young girl or a guy as
a subject of a targeted hate campaign my
be ok so please remember at the center
of every viral storm is a human being
so she's just saying like you know all
your comments that you're saying it
could be very hurtful and to just be
aware that these are humans are touched
I think people know that they're hurtful
that's why they're trying to they want
to hurt they're trying to get a reaction
I know you're a human but you're also a
stupid human I'm kidding come well I
don't know what the haters would say
today I want to I want to hear like
someone go I am a week 23 year old
little girl like everyone's gotta like
what's what this strong woman mean I
have to say I'm a strong woman as
opposed to just saying you're a woman
what can't a woman on its own be strong
please s say you're strong it's supposed
insecure sounding should I've ever heard
independent I am a 24 year old
disenfranchised minority from the United
States of America that's gone through a
lot of hardships and overcame obstacles
it was your question yeah no right it's
always like that I gotta qualify who I
ended up give me a litany before I got
some questions when people have to say
like as a as a disenfranchised minority
I think this or like whenever they make
a statement they got to be like as a
doctor I think this or whatever the
other I show their dick before they
could say anything yeah well that's a
shock small their dick is so they can
talk about dick issues real quick it's
like okay we get it man your dick it
doesn't work so good oh yeah I can't
[ __ ] I can't get sucked
I can't stroke I can't even touch it
sorry buddy it's a guest so what do you
think I could but this pretty [ __ ] you
said yourself you're pretty [ __ ] I
don't know you should just start
responding like as a board man on the
internet I would whatever whatever
that's exactly yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]